افاد وزير الداخليه الفرنسي باصابه سته
اشخاص بينهم اربعه اطفال في هجوم بسكين
بمدينه انسي جنوب شرقي البلاد معلنا القاء
القبض على المهاجم وقالت مصادر ان منفذه
الهجوم السوريه الجنسيه من مواليد عام 91
وهو حاصل على صفه لاجئ ودخل فرنسا بطريقه
قانونيه وقال الرئيس الفرنسي
في حاله صدمه بعد الهجوم
معنى الامن باريس مراسل للجزيره محمد
البقالي نرحب بك محمد واخذ من ما قاله
الرئيس الفرنسي من ان فرنسا في حاله صدمه
هل ماتزال فرنسا في حاله صدمه وهل رشحت اي
معلومات اضافيه حول هذا الهجوم فيما يتعلق
بالدوافع والاسباب وما الى ذلك
صدمه مثل هذه ازدهار لا تتبدد سريعا صدمه
مثل هذه سيتذكرها الفرنسيون طويلا لان هذه
من المرات القلائل جدا التي يتم فيها
استهداف اطفال صغار ومنهم من لم تتجاوز
اعمارهم الثالثه من العمر المهاجم استهدف
حديقه اطفال يوجد فيها صغار رفقه ابائهم
بسكين
والحصيله الان ان سته اشخاص اصيبوا بجروح
بالغه من بينهم اربعه اطفال اقل من ثلاث
سنوات
طفلين من بين هؤلاء هم في حاله خطره جدا
ومصادر طبيه قالت انهما بين الموت والحياه
وبالتالي هذا هو الذي يشرح حاله الصدمه
التي توجد عليها فرنسا ويوجد عليها
الحقيقه الجميع وكل من سمع بهذا الخبر
المهاجم هناك معطيات في الحقيقه مثيره
للانتباه المهاجر اللاجئ حاصل على اللجوء
موفي السويد منذ عام
سوري الاصل لديه متزوج ولديه طفل عمره
ثلاث سنوات متزوج بسيده سويديه لحد اللحظه
السؤال المطروح هو ما هي دوافع هذا الهجوم
مكتب مكافحه الارهاب لم يدخل على الخط
وهذا ما يعني ان السلطات الفرنسيه ترجح
لحد اللحظه ان الامر ليست له دوافع
ارهابيه ولكن مصادر الشرطه وشهود عيان
يقول تقول بان الشخص وهو شاب في الثانيه
وثلاثين من عمره يبدو انه مسيحي مسيحي
الديانه هذا هو ما كان قد صرح به عند طلبه
للجوء لانه حاول علاوه على صفه اللاجئ
التي حصل عليها في السويد حاول ان يحصل
على صفه لاجئ في فرنسا وصرح لحظتها للشرطه
بانه من مسيحه سوريا كما انه يقيم في
السويد في منطقه معروفه بانها مسيحه الشرق
كان يحمل وفقا لشهود عيان صليبا
وانجيلا اثناء محاولته او اثناء هجومه على
هؤلاء الذين صادفهم في طريقه
وبالتالي فالشخص وطبيعته وديانته واسمه
عبد المسيح كل هذا اربك السلطات الفرنسيه
على مستوى تصنيف العمليه لانه دعني اقول
دعيني اقول ازدهار بانه لم يسبق في فرنسا
ان تم تصنيف اي عمليه او اي هجوم لم ينفذه
مسلم على انه ارهابي بغض النظر عن طبيعه
الهجوم حتى ان كثيرا كثيرا من المسلمين
هنا يتساءلون هل اصبح من شرط تصنيف
العمليه على انها ارهابيه ان يكون المنفذ
مسلم الديانه على كل حال لحد الان
المعطيات المتوفره تقول بان المهاجم كان
يحمل انجيلا وصرخ باسم المسيح اثناء
تنفيذه هذه العمليه هذه معطيات على كل حال
تم تجميعها من هنا ومن هناك بعد قليل
ستكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي لرئيسه الوزراء
ووزير الداخليه وللمدعي العام وحينها
ستتبين معطيات اكثر من الامور السابقه
شكرا لك من باريس مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي